your team all the best, secure
and Barnes with mercy corps,
thank you so much.
>> Thank you.
>> Nato secretary general has
made a clear that allies will
continue to support Ukraine for
as long as it takes, as the war
now nears the one year mark.
Jens Thunberg's comments came
as the nato defense minister
met in Brussels.
Also in attendance, Ukraine's
defense minister, who said
Russia is the most significant
and direct threat to nato
countries.
And that Ukrainian soldiers are
defending all of Europe.
Nato's chief reaffirmed the
commitment to helping Ukraine.
>> Nato allies are providing
unprecedented support to
Ukraine to help uphold its
right of self-defense.
And from the start, we have
been working very closely with
the European union in terms of
support for Ukraine as long as
it takes.
>> [Sound of gunfire]
>> Ukrainian forces are now
doing fierce fighting on the
front lines in the, east where
Ukraine says Russian troops are
continuing offensives from the
air and on the ground in the
donetsk region.
But what is among the cities
that's been targeted by Russian
attacks.
Ukrainian president volodymyr
zelenskyy says that his
soldiers are facing a tough
fight.
>> Translator: The situation on
the front line, especially in
the donetsk and luhansk regions
remains extremely difficult.
It is literally a battle for
every meter of Ukrainian land.
We must understand the
significance of the battle.
Every meter one is to defend
our entire country.
>> CNN's David Mckenzie is
following developments and has
more on the battle raging
between Ukraine and Russia on
the front lines.
>> Thousands of miles from the
front lines, the cemetery in
Russia's far east.
For young men cut down in
relentless ways of attack.
Off camera, a woman's ops and
says, our boys.
>> Soldiers of the 155th marine
breed, the NSA can catastrophic
dark this.
For weeks, the coal mining town
of the epicenter of the Russian
efforts to breakthrough enemy
lines.
But the result here has been a
disaster.
At least 50 Russian tanks the
short by Ukraine minds and
artillery, a scrambled chaotic
retreat.
.
Across the front, Ukrainians
are well dug in, there are
lines aren't moving.
>> But this soldier says that
there are now ten attacks a day,
used to be just a couple.
To the north, the Russians are
inching forward around bakhmut,
and every exit from the city is
extremely dangerous.
The battles here a close
quarters and relenting trench
warfare near to the city.
>> It's so hard, the enemy is
pushing from different
directions, says this Ukrainian
soldier.
All the efforts men are making
our priceless.
Fighters of the Wagner
mercenary group paraded their
flag on a village at the
outskirts of bakhmut, but they
are being forced to fight for
every single house, and Wagner
boss if ghani prigozhin --
but will not be take it
tomorrow because there is heavy
resistance and grinding, for
the meat grinder to work
properly, it is impossible to
suddenly start disabilities.
This as Wagner units continue
to endure heavy losses in its
efforts on the heels around
bakhmut, with their
vulnerability to Ukrainian
artillery and drones.
Ukrainian officials now expect
another Russian thrust from the
north in the force near crimea.
There's been fierce fighting
here for, weeks a Russian
advance here would allow the
Kremlin to claim it's captured
all of the luhansk region, a
key objective of Vladimir
Putin's war.
But Ukrainians are putting up
stiff resistance, and their
allies expect that in the
spring, they may be able to
launch attacks of their own.
If they are supplied the
weapons and ammunition they
need.
>> We believe that there will
be a window of opportunity for
them to exercise their
initiative, and then change or
continue to create direct
conditions on the battlefield.
>> Before that, along this vast
front, the Ukrainians must hold
off what they expect to be an
imminent Russian onslaught.
David Mckenzie, CNN, Kyiv.
>> Joining us from Washington
is David singer, a senior
political and national security
analyst and white house
correspondent for the New York
Times.
He joins us now from D.C..
Good to see you, David.
>> Great to be back with you,
Lynda.
>> So the west is continuing to
promise to support Ukraine for
as long as it takes.
Looking at the way that this
war has unfolded, how long do
you think that could be?
>> >> Well it could be years,
it depends on whether or not
either the counter offensives
that the Ukrainians are hoping
for this offensive that appears
to have begun, at least in a
low to medium level by the
Russians actually results in a
significant change on the
ground.
If it does not, if we're in for
the long slog, then the
Russians and Ukraine's will be
battling over the south and
east and the Russians will be
looking for a moment where they
can provide the hopes for
taking the whole country, we
think that is a reach too far
for them right now.
The question is has this become
a frozen conflict and
exhilarated version of what
happened after the invasion of
crimea in 2014 and of the south
and east of Ukraine shortly
thereafter.
Or does this become an all out
conflict in which the Russians
go beyond Ukraine's borders and
take on nato nations?
So far, they've shown no
interest in doing so >> I want
to ask you, David, about the
weapons.
The Ukrainian president
zelenskyy made it clear that
speed is key, not just shifting
weapons but training troops
given the spring offensive but
there are big problems.
Much of what has been promised,
armored tanks, longer range
missiles, some of which have
not been built yet, how big a
problem is that in terms of
getting those weapons that have
been promised into the hands of
fighters on the front lines.
>> There is an increasing
mismatch between western
promises and what we're able to
deliver.
In the early days of the war,
when the Ukrainians mostly
needed anti-aircraft, very
light weapons, javelins,
portable airplanes and tank
killers, there were a fair
number of those around.
They were in storage, could be
handed to the Ukrainians pretty
quickly.
We're in a very different
situation.
The war has moved to what is
essentially more than artillery
conflict in the flatlands of
the south and the east.
They run through a huge amount
of ammunition, and it's clearly
not possible right now for the
U.S. To continue to keep up.
The easy stores of older
weapons have been exhausted,
and now, the U.S., when a
promises weapons, is basically
putting them on order and the
factory.
That's what they did with the
Abrams tanks, and that means it
could be months, could be more
than a year before they get
that delivered, and what you're
hearing from zelenskyy,
president zelenskyy is, he is
saying, look, I don't have a
year, I don't even have three
months.
I need the weapons now because
they are starting their counter
offensive or hope to soon.
>> And high on the wish list
for zelenskyy, is fighter jets,
and that's --
the receiving training in print,
but even if those fighter jets
are promised, that will happen
quickly.
Why is that this reluctance,
David, to offer those?
>> The reluctance on president
Biden's part comes from the
fact that those jets can reach
well into Russia.
They could bomb Moscow, and
while the Ukrainians say that
is not their intent, this is
the way the work could escalate
quite rapidly, and turned into
a U.S. Russia war for a nato
Russia war.
Consistently, you have heard
president Biden offer to
different objectives here.
One is, he says we will support
the Ukrainians.
The second is, he says, we will
not get into World War III.
Well, Putin has sensed the
vulnerability that the second
criteria creates, and that is
why episodically, you hear him
out there and to use nuclear
weapons and so forth.
He's clearly trying to say to
Biden, there are some
parameters here, and if the
Ukrainians are going after
crimea, which of course, Russia
sees in 2014, if they are going
after Moscow, if they're going
after Russian infrastructure,
that would be what would
trigger a larger or.